découdre comme ça du malheur mais quel
est le rapport avec la réducation mais
c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
mobilisation en hausse pour ce quatrième
samedi de manifestations contre le pas
salutaire et la vaccination obligatoire
deux cent trente sept mille personnes
ont manifesté partout en france d'après
les chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur
ces vingt-huit mille de plus que samedi
dernier le syndicat france police
policiers en colère évoquait déjà à 15
heures la participation de 480 milles
magnifique
[Musique]
l'afghanistan sombre petit à petit dans
les mains des talibans les rebelles ont
conquis deux villes dans les régions
frontalières avec les rangs l'onu
s'inquiète de cette escalade de violence
route année
on rappelle leurs ressortissants à
quitter le pays au vu du jeu suite d'une
situation sécuritaire qui empire
[Musique]
gouvernement leur prix d'émission la
colère gronde en thaïlande où des
manifestants manifestations sont
organisées pour réclamer le départ du
premier ministre
l'exécutif est en effet
responsable de la situation sanitaire et
économique du pays et la police qui a
fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes et de
balles en caoutchouc aujourd'hui pour
disperser les manifestants
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue ici vous retrouver sur
rtl france la mobilisation contre le
pass année tard et la vaccination
obligatoire progressent pour ce 4e
samedis consécutifs
ils étaient 230 7000 manifestants
partout en france d'après le ministère
de l'intérieur ces vingt-huit mille de
plus que samedi dernier le syndicat
france police policiers en colère évoqué
à 15 heures la participation de 480
mille personnes
près de 200 rassemblements étaient
organisés à travers le pays est les
forces de l'ordre ont procédé à 35
interpellations au total et déplore sept
blessés légers parmi leurs rangs à paris
quatre rassemblements étaient organisés
en par des gilets jaunes en autres à
l'appel de florian philippot est les
autorités évoquent le chiffre de 17
mille manifestants dans la capitale
notre reporter david kelly a fait le
point sur la manifestation organisée par
le leader des patriotes
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées à l'initiative de florian
philippot le chef dé file des patriotes
1 pour protester contre l'extension de
ce pass and iter est ce projet de loi
qu'ils jugent liberticide
partis de la place joffre pour rejoindre
la place vauban la pluie a eu raison des
derniers manifestants une scène a été
érigée quentin qui est en train de se
démonter derrière moi actuellement une
scène où plusieurs prises de parole en
public se sont succédés notamment
florian philippot le chef de file des
patriotes ou encore nicolas dupont
aignan un chef de file de debout la
france tous deux ont exprimé leur regret
un devoir la démocratie est en danger en
face à ce nouveau projet de loi qui sera
en vigueur dès lundi projet de loi et
qui a été a mises en place pour lutter
contre le coc vide à 19 selon l'exécutif
je vous le disais plusieurs milliers de
manifestants réunis afin de protester et
de montrer leur colère
malgré la validation du conseil
constitutionnel ils ne lâcheront pas et
continueront à battre le pavé pour faire
valoir leurs droits écoutez je sais qu'à
d'autres
d'autres personnes qui disent que c'est
pour qu'ils vainquent c'est tout mais
non en fait c'est juste que voilà le
passé on sépare pas les gens' entre deux
catégories français n'a jamais fait dans
le public on le fera jamais donc je
pense qu'il ya 80% des gens c'est comme
ça tout ça ça provoquera juste des
séparations qui n'ont pas de lieu et
c'est pire quand il s'agit justement de
passer ni terre pour entrer à l'hôpital
ça va littéralement provoqué des morts
parce qu'à des maladies qui doivent être
traitées en avance et quand il est
urgent parce que c'est ce qu'ils ont
indiqué il doit venir seulement quand
c'est urgent parfois il est trop tard si
elle n'aurait pas été retrouvée
en avance et beaucoup de gens ne
viendront pas parce qu'on les a forcées
et ils ont peur ils ont peur parce que
évidemment il s'agit de leur corps et
c'est très invasif
naïvement je pensais que le conseil
constitutionnel n'a les allers-retours
qu'est cette loi et nous on est parent
tout est différent je pense encore plus
de monde donc je suis là pour soutenir
en a tant de policiers et beaucoup de
policiers soutiennent aussi
ces gens là puisqu'on doit pas avoir des
citoyens enfin une citoyenneté à deux
vitesses tout simplement personnel et la
vendetta on est payés une misère et
maintenant on nous impose un produit
dans notre corps on n'a pas le choix et
je trouve ça inadmissible tout
simplement un rassemblement qui s'est
déroulé dans une ambiance assez un
cordial encadrés par un important
dispositif de sécurité didier lallement
avait mobilisé près de trois mille
gendarmes et policiers 1 pour éviter à
tout débordement durant cette
mobilisation et les autres
rassemblements également aucun
débordement à signaler à savoir que les
manifestations vont se poursuivre d'ici
à l'été prochain samedi et est les
manifestants ne lâcheront pas tant
qu'ils ne se feront pas entendre c'est
en tout cas à ce qu'on a pu ressentir
ici est cet après midi ils ne lâcheront
pas même si le conseil constitutionnel a
validé ce projet de loi qu'ils estiment
liberticide
florian philippot françois flynn ou
encore nicolas dupont aignan plusieurs
personnalités politiques ont participé à
cette manifestation aujourd'hui je vous
propose de les écouter les gens ont vu
qu'ils étaient trahi attaquer par toutes
leurs institutions du parlement au
gouvernement en passant par le conseil
d'état et conseil constitutionnel bien
sûr
le souverain en france ce ne sont pas
eux c'est le peuple et le peuple de
france va rappeler va rappeler très
fortement aujourd'hui ici à paris
partout en france que le souverain c'est
lui qui ne veut pas une société
d'apartheid qui ne veut pas une société
de ségrégation et de séparation qui ne
veut pas société liberticide
il veut qu'on revienne vers quelque
chose de beaucoup plus humain et de
beaucoup plus conforme à nos valeurs
pourquoi est-ce qu'à des professions
comme les forces de l'anp qui sont
exemptés et d'autres comme et sapeurs
pompiers qui ne le sont pas ça prouve
que ça n'est pas quelque chose de
scientifique duc sanitaire c'est quelque
chose de politique et surtout les
français ont compris que ce qui se cache
derrière c'est une évolution de la
société vers un contrôle social de plus
en plus important à la chinoise comme
notamment le
comme notamment le crédit social chinois
et c'est pour ça que les français se
mobilisent c'est qu'ils ne veulent pas
c'est pas seulement la sphère de la
colle vie ne s'est pas seulement la
sphère de la vaccination du pass
sanitaire c'est beaucoup plus que ça nos
société de surveillance généralisée de
type orwelliens qu'il refuse d'abord le
peuple français et le peuple de la
liberté
et on peut protéger la santé des
français lutter contre l'épidémie en
respectant nos principes fondateurs
liberté égalité premier point dans les
prochains jours il faut d'abord qu'elle
maximum de français qui manifestent
sereinement calmement sans tomber dans
les provocations du pouvoir qui divise
il faut ensuite que les français par la
pratique civique à y soutenir ceux qui
résistent les restaurateurs qui
regarderont pas le pass ceux qui
résistent et il faut que le pass ne
disparaisse de lui-même parce que les
français l'auront finalement contourné
et puis enfin il faudra que les français
aillent voter massivement pour chasser
l'oligarque client est en train de tuer
l'esprit de la france c'est ça l'enjeu
et les trois vont ensemble manifestation
calme le résistance passive calme aussi
pour vider de son sens le pass et puis
suffrage universel pour en finir avec
l'oligarchie est toujours un sujet vous
voyez la vie de pierre jeantet remaniant
radiologues et membre de l'union
régionale des professionnels santé et de
denis millet co président départemental
de la fédération des syndicats
pharmaceutiques de france il ya eu quand
même ne rappelle al par l'ordre national
des médecins qui dit qu'on peut pas
quand même privé les gens d'un accès au
soin autant je suis effectivement
partisans de stopper les possibilités de
contamination dans tout ce qui n'est pas
on va dire santé parce que quelque part
au final c'est nous qui trinquons en
tant que citoyen mais sur la santé vous
devez temps et maintenir la capacité des
gens alors peut-être pas sur le droit de
visite c'est vrai comment voulez-vous
décrétée par quelqu'un qui effectivement
en état de couleurs le dis c'est pas les
la puissance publique
c'est souvent une société de sauvetage
comment cette personne n'est en capacité
de juger que la
la personne vient elle n'est pas d'ordre
national d'urgence non septembre il faut
qu'on puisse accéder librement aux
structures de soins qu'elle soit en
cabinet qu'elle soit en établissement
par contre il faut effectivement
verrouiller le reste parce que la
situation devient tendue
trois régions métropolitaines sont déjà
avec un plan blanc activer ses terres
qu'on en est à rappeler les soignants y
compris à l'étranger
on sait que le vaccin est efficace on
sait qu'ils protègent on sait qu'ils
empêchent de diffuser de manière assez
bas civils encore une étude qu'ils ont
entendu parler d'études ce matin encore
qui disait la même chose donc je pense
que ça c'est une évidence il faut il
faut pas la nier maintenant le fait que
le gouvernement ait voulu passer de
manière un petit peu jaillir en douce et
c'est un peu ça en disant on va vous
obliger à le faire parce que si vous
voulez vivre normalement il faudra que
vous ayez votre pas salutaire c'est vrai
que c'est ça qui peut provoquer la
colère et sa vache folle à comprendre et
d une agression pharmacie pendant les
manifestations de la saison c'est
incompréhensible je pense qu'il faut
appeler au calme les gens qui sont dans
la rue
les pharmaciens il fait son travail et
les contacts qu'ils vaccinent pas ce que
ça se crée sa conviction qu'il faut le
faire
il fait des tests il est là pour la
sortie publique qui a pas aucune raison
d'attaquer une pharmacie où je voulais
attirer l'attention sur ce point là pas
vraiment très grave
et s'ils sont aujourd'hui plus de 44
millions de français avoir reçu au moins
une dose de sérum anti qu'ovide d'autres
se disent méfiants estime qu'il n'y a
pas suffisamment de recul sur
l'efficacité de ces vaccins en 2019 déjà
d'après une étude 41% des sondés se
déclaraient méfiants à l'égard des
vaccins contre 17 % dans le reste des
pays européens
une méfiance à l'égard de la vaccination
qui n'est pas nouvelle et qui remonte à
plusieurs siècles en arrière donc avant
la crise du coronavirus regarder
[Musique]
et outre l'extension du passé ni terre
le conseil constitutionnel s'est
prononcé hier sur un référendum
d'initiative partagée sur l'hôpital un
projet retoqué par les sages porté par
des parlementaires issus de la gauche et
de la droite voulant défendre d'une même
voix je cite un bien commun un texte
avec un article jugé contraire à la
constitution
principal objectif de cette requête
augmenter les moyens des hôpitaux en
particulier en termes de lits et de
soignants marie pierre martin infirmière
à paris et membre du collectif inter
urgence évoque un problème structurel
antérieures à la crise du coc vide
depuis depuis 10e ou 18 mois avec la
crise qu vide on se rend bien compte que
l'hôpital il est pas du tout en mesure
de prendre en charge les français
correctement on n'est pas en mesure de
faire des soins de qualité et avec le
collectif en interrogeant ça faisait
déjà deux ans qu ont été mobilisés même
deux ans et demi maintenant ça fait ça
fait un an et demi qu'on a une crise
sanitaire qui secoue l'hôpital où on
tient les murs corps on peut ou on
demande plus de moyens à tort et à
travers en vain aujourd'hui comment
voulez aller faire un métier où vous
allez forcément devoir remettre en cause
vos valeurs et vos valeurs
professionnelles parce que vous n'avez
pas les moyens de le faire comme vous
voulez l'attractivité s'est pas
uniquement le salaire c'est aussi être
en mesure de prendre en soit nos
patients correctement de pas être dans
des politiques de de rentabilité en
permanence ce qui est actuellement c'est
le cas un an que le projet a été initié
neuf mois que l' usine fonctionne la
coop des masques basée à grasse près de
guingamp pour objectif de sécuriser
l'approvisionnement des masques pour les
professionnels
cette société coopérative d'intérêt
collectif lancé par des citoyens et des
collectivités territoriales continuent
de se développer toujours dans vos
soucis de respect social et de
l'environnement reportage renault
parquet nicolas petit
les rubans de tissus tourne quasiment 16
heures par jour pour cela deux équipes
se relaient nordine appartient à
l'équipe du matin
il est conducteur de ligne nous on a
vraiment une surveillance de la machine
un ravitaillement en fait on doit
effectuer un ravitaillement pour qu'elle
tombe jamais en rupture en fait est
qu'elle s'arrête jamais donc on est à
peu près sur une production de 150
masque à la minute
donc ce qui fait à peu près d'une 9000
masquer un peu près à l'heure on est sur
une production allez on va dire entre
les deux équipes on est à peu près à 100
mille masques sur une journée outre la
production locale
la coop des masques repose sur une
philosophie démocratique et sociale
chaque salarié est sociétaire chaque
citoyen qui y participent a également un
droit de regard et le recrutement se
fait sans véritable sélection dans l'adn
de la colle des masques on a essayé
d'avoir une mixité complète au niveau
des recrutements ce soit en termes
hommes femmes en termes personnes âgées
personnes plus jeunes et au niveau six
travailleurs reconnaissance un handicap
est donc aujourd'hui on a 30 % de nos
salariés qui sont en reconnaissance de
travailleur handicapé et avec les
recrutements à venir on va essayer de
garder ce niveau de travailleurs
handicapés
la structure continue d'embaucher d'ici
à septembre
elle devrait recruter sept nouvelles
personnes grâce notamment à l'arrivée
d'une nouvelle machine capable de
produire du mail blosne un filtre
extérieur au masque et seuls composants
encore importer on manque juste de
100000 euros pour pouvoir avoir cette
machine donc on fait un appel à
mobilisation de tous les citoyens de
tous les sociétaires de tous les usagers
qui veulent participer à notre
entreprise et
un autre aventure coopérative et
solidaire il manque c'est cela pour
qu'on puisse avoir cette machine et
devenir vraiment fabricant de mel blanc
pour notre propre production mais aussi
pour en vendre industriels français tels
que fabricant de couches ou filtre de
moteurs automobiles etc
une filière de recyclage et une
production de masques en matières
végétales sont également à l'étude
si la coop des masques compte
aujourd'hui 1900 sociétaires il faudrait
que ce nombre grossistes pour passer à
trois équipes par jour et mener à bien
l'ensemble de ces projets la dernière
entreprise française de fabrication de
masques à destination du personnel
médical était elle aussi implanté dans
les côtes d'armor
lâché par l'état qui s'est désengagé de
ses commandes à la ferme et en 2018
trois ans plus tard laventure de la coop
des masques en terre bretonne sonne
comme une revanche du destin
l'afghanistan est un tournant dangereux
flénu averti après le conseil de
sécurité consacrée à la situation du
pays qui s'est tenue hier et pour cause
de nouvelles villes sont tombées aux
mains des talibans des rebelles qu'ils
ne s'attaquent plus uniquement campagne
met au centre urbain dorénavant leur
message est clair la prise de la
capitale ne serait tarder alors l'armée
régulière essaient de résister et de
nombreux afghans ont fui les combats
les habitants à kaboul se disait
inquiète
si vous demandez à la plupart des
afghans 99% d'entre vous diront que les
combats ne résoudront pas les crises
actuelles
la seule solution c'est la paix et c'est
ce que veut le peuple afghan dans les
deux camps les personnes tuées sont des
afghans et sont originaires de ce pays
la guerre n'entraîne que misère et
destruction tout le monde est pour mais
quoi qu'il arrive tout le monde n'a pas
les moyens de fuir le pays
tous les partis devraient s'asseoir et
discuter pour résoudre les problèmes par
le dialogue
non seulement la ville des oranges à
nîmes heureuse est en danger mais
d'autres provinces du nord comme la
ville de mazar i sharif
douze jeunes parole koundouz baronne et
pula congrès sont assiégées les talibans
se sont rapprochés des villes de
nombreuses personnes ont dû fuir à cause
de la guerre et se sont installés à
kaboul le conflit sanglant entre les
talibans et l'armée comme à chaque
guerre les dommages collatéraux sont
importants les villes sont détruites
elle est citoyen fui près d'un million
de déplacés en trois mois à cause des
violences selon la commission afghane
indépendante des droits humains amaya
soubelet
ce scénario devenu monnaie courante le
déplacement de familles afghanes face à
l'avancée des talibans dans la province
de takhar à taloqan la population à pied
ou à bord de camions je suis les zones
dangereuses
les moudjahidine sont venus et nous ont
ordonné de quitter notre maison
j'ai quitté ma maison et je suis venu à
dakar je ne sais pas où nous devons
aller où vivre et nous amuser pourquoi
nous souffrons de telles difficultés
maintenant la situation sécuritaire
attaque arts s'est gravement détérioré
les opérateurs de changes ton ferme et
les marchés sont fermés dans leur
ensemble
non loin de là les forces afghanes
tentent de repousser les insurgés qui
contrôlent désormais une grande partie
de la province 177 blessés ont dû être
emmenées à l'hôpital
alors que les soldats de takhar ont en
partie repousser les attaques
le groupe terroriste nous attaquer nous
avons lutté et nous nous sommes défendus
nous leur avons infligé de lourdes
pertes et nous avons vaincu l'ennemi
un ennemi qui encercle eu malgré tout
toute la province
cannon isolé puisque depuis trois mois
le groupe islamiste gagne de plus en
plus de territoire
depuis peu ils menacent de s'emparer des
rates lashkar gah et kandar trois
grandes villes d'afghanistan les zones
rurales comme urbaines sont désormais
ciblées et la défense afghane est de
plus en plus compliqué preuve en est ce
vendredi zahran ge est devenue la
première capitale provinciale sous le
contrôle taliban depuis le début de leur
offensive
ce mercredi lyon les talibans ont
revendiqué l'attentât contre la maison
du ministre de la défense à kaboul
une opération de représailles fermement
assumer après la salve eu de
bombardements aériens opérés par les
soldats afghans
israël annonce ce matin avoir mené la
nuit dernière des frappes aériennes sur
des cibles du hamas à gaza et ce en
représailles à des lancers de ballons
incendiaires envoyé par le mouvement
depuis l'enclavé palestinienne
il s'agit de la deuxième confrontation
de ce type en dix jours dans la région
entre les deux parties des offensives
qui interviennent au lendemain de
frappes et de raids aériens à la
frontière libano-israélienne entre
l'état hébreu et le hezbollah une
escalade dans le sud liban qui inquiète
l'onu les états unis ont appelé beyrouth
à contrôler la région
le chef du hezbollah hassan nasrallah
doit à d'ailleurs tenir aujourd'hui un
discours télévisé quinze ans après la
dernière guerre avec israël et précision
avec walid bennani un char de tsahal qui
défend ses positions des tirs de
roquettes libanais qui traversent la
frontière israélienne et des habitants
de plusieurs villages qui ne peuvent que
constater des dégâts c'était une frappe
forte très forte nous avons eu
l'impression que la maison allait
s'effondrer
nous avons attendu un peu et même pas
dix minutes plus tard il y a eu une
autre frappe voix va matin la situation
est tendue
nous avons vécu une période similaire
dans les années 70 lorsque les
combattants palestiniens mener des
attaques de guérilla contre israël
nous en sommes maintenant même point et
cela provoque des tensions elle la
crainte d'une escalade perceptible dans
l'émoi de ses résidents libanais depuis
jeudi les deux camps se renvoient la
responsabilité de cette nouvelle montée
des tensions avec des déclarations
fortes
le porte parole de l'armée israélienne a
pointé du doigt les actions du mouvement
chiite libanais hezbollah très influent
dans le sud du liban saâles qui a
reconnu aussi des raids aériens au pays
du cèdre des actions inédites depuis
nous ne voulons pas d'une escalade en
vue d'une véritable guerre mais bien sûr
nous sommes prêts à cela et nous ne
permettrons pas à ces actes terroristes
de continuer en réponse aux raids
aériens israéliens
la résistance islamique a bombardé avec
des dizaines de roquettes
un territoire près des positions des
forces d'occupation israéliennes dans la
région des fermes de chébaa les fermes
de chébaa petit territoire que réclame
notamment libanais ici rien israël s
beau la détention qui n'ont jamais cessé
de s'arrêter une grande guerre en 2006
avec plus de 1200 civils libanais et 160
israéliens tués en un mois sans oublier
des frictions en 2019 et en juillet
dernier avec l'attak d'un pétrolier
appartenant au milliardaire israélien
emmerd oman l'état hébreu accuse téhéran
qui dément la république islamique
d'iran soutien historique du hezbollah
ray cochet pression et actions sur le
terrain qui inquiète la communauté
internationale
le chef de mission et commandant de la
force de la finul le général de division
stefano d'alcool a été en contact
immédiat avec les parties il les a
exhortés à cesser le feu et à faire
preuve d'un maximum de retenue pour
éviter toute nouvelle escalade
l'armée israélienne a informé que le
hezbollah renvoyer surtout un message en
visant des zones non habitées selon elle
une guerre totale et pour l'heure à
exclure
je vous le disais en titre des heurts
ont éclaté ce samedi entre manifestants
et policiers à bangkok en thaïlande ils
étaient des milliers descendus dans les
rues pour réclamer la démission du
premier ministre qu'ils jugent
responsable de la situation sanitaire et
économique du pays est les détails avec
françois tessier beach il n'a pas fallu
longtemps avant que la situation
dégénère
[Musique]
alors que les manifestants anti
gouvernement se diriger vers la
résidence du premier ministre
ils se sont rapidement heurté à une
forte résistance policière
[Musique]
et c'est ce que nous avons vu jusqu'à
présent ce sont les ripostes de la
police contre les manifestants qui
lancent des pétards des grenades
artisanales et des billes sur la police
est ce que la police a fait c'est de
suivre strictement les mesures et les
opérations de police fondée sur les lois
nationales et des lois internationales
avec les normes internationales
bravant l'interdiction de rassemblement
les protestataires réclament la
démission du premier ministre
prayut chan-o-cha responsable selon eux
de la situation actuelle du pays
l'absence de touristes depuis mars 2020
illustration de la stratégie zéro
qu'ovide mis en place en thaïlande mais
la population dans une situation
difficile d'autant que le pays
relativement épargnée par la pandémie
jusque là est désormais rattrapé par le
vaillant delta et que la vaccination a
pris du retard
malgré les promesses des autorités à
peine 11 des 70 millions de thaïlandais
ont reçu à ce jour au moins une première
injection
une situation sanitaire et économique
qui a ravivé un mouvement initié l'année
dernière réclamant une nouvelle
constitution une réforme en profondeur
de la monarchie un sujet jusqu'alors
tabou dans un pays où la famille royale
est considéré comme intouchable
ces revendications ne propose pas de se
débarrasser de la monarchie ce sont des
propositions avec de bonnes intentions
pour que l'institution de la monarchie
reste bienveillante au dessus du peuple
sous un régime démocratique
depuis les premières contestations
plus de 100 thaïlandais sont poursuivis
pour délit de lèse majesté
un crime passible de 15 ans
d'emprisonnement
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi jour trouve dans vingt
peu plus d'une trentaine de minutes pour
un nouveau point sur l'information à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
en suisse un fonctionnement politique
très particulier elle permet à ses
citoyens de se prononcer sur les lois
temps proposé et même de les faire
retirer éventuellement en suisse il ya
nos outils le premier qui permet
d'attaquer les lois l'autre instrument
c'est l'initiative populaire qui permet
d'être duire un nouvel article de la
constitution le foot même que un sujet
aride en votation signifie qu'il ya un
problème
ce qui oblige les les partenaires comme
tic à se remettre autour de la table les
stériles pourrait pas y avoir de dérive
populiste vrai que leurs proches du
risque doit d'avoir des votations